nearly a hundred percent of russia's
combat forces from the border have now
entered ukraine russia's throwing
everything it has into battle even
recruiting syrians to come wage urban
warfare on its behalf
heavy battles raging in the south
mcglade is the scene of massive fighting
as russian ground forces threaten to
strangle the entire south and move
towards the key port city of odessa the
black sea coast is in trouble
as the russian military is making more
progress there than in the north
zielinski is begging
for more air support from the west
yesterday secretary of state tony
blinken said the u.s wouldn't stand in
the way of any nato members offering to
support ukraine
if for instance the polish government a
nato member wants to send fighter jets
does that get a green light from the u.s
are you afraid that that will escalate
tension
no that that that gets a green light in
fact we're talking uh with uh our polish
friends right now about what we might be
able to do to backfill uh their needs if
in fact they choose to provide these
fighter jets to to the ukrainians and
zielinski doesn't think warplanes are
enough he's still pleading for a no-fly
zone over ukraine with nato
continuing to shut it down
but voices in the west are growing
louder for a no-fly zone
putin saying if that happens it could be
considered an act of war
now we are hearing that a no-fly zone
must be established over the territory
of ukraine but any move in this
direction will be viewed by us as a
participation in the armed conflict of
whichever side whose territory will pose
a threat to our service members
vladimir putin even threatened a nuclear
response over a no-fly zone i'm afraid
we could be hurdling ourselves into a
deadly war that we can't stop
for years we've been dangling nato
membership over ukraine's head
actively flirting with them to join our
alliance as far back as 2009
biden was tempting ukraine with the nato
offer
telling their then president that quote
if you choose to be a part of the
euro-atlantic integration which i
believe you have then we strongly
support that
we do not recognize any sphere of
influence we do not recognize anyone
else's right to dictate to you or any
other country what alliances you seek to
belong to
we signed up ukraine as a nato partner
state a year ago
was that a good idea
we kept telling them a little more has
to be done you're almost there just
clean up your corruption
then this november 10th
it changed everything
the biden administration and ukraine
signed a charter on strategic
partnership
saying that the u.s supports ukraine
joining nato
putin saw this as a direct act against
them
it was an assurance to ukraine that
they're almost there
and that they're meeting their criteria
that natum had told them to meet
the agreement said the u.s will quote
emphasize unwavering commitment to
ukraine's sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
including crimea and extending to its
territorial waters
in the face of ongoing russian
aggression which threatens regional
peace and stability and undermines the
global rule-based order
this move directly taunted putin he was
furious and accelerated his mobilization
against his neighbor
did we have a plan for ukraine
what did we expect
when they were this close to nato
membership
well we either didn't have a plan for a
russian reaction
didn't think russia would react
or we're watching our plan play out
right now
hillary clinton
hinted at the plan last week
turn ukraine
into a killing field to bleed russia dry
listen
remember uh the russians invaded
afghanistan uh back in 1980
it didn't end well for the russians the
fact is that a very
motivated and then
funded and armed insurgency
basically drove the russians out of
afghanistan i think that is the model
that people are now uh looking toward
so what we're watching unfold on the
ground in ukraine a horrible ground war
that moves to a western funded
insurgency
that after many many years
sends russia packing
is a model
we're watching a proxy war
ukraine wanted biden to send them the
iron dome missile defense system
this is the joint venture between the
united states and israel but israel in
the united states shot that down
the biden administration and the
israelis said they didn't want to anger
russia
wouldn't let them defend themselves
that would have been essentially a
no-fly zone having the iron dome
so while innocent ukrainian families are
dying putin's forces are getting pretty
run down too
but we're buying russian oil
so we're funding both sides
why are we doing that
nobody wins here
ukraine's becoming a graveyard
how did nobody in washington see this
coming
or did they and they didn't do anything
about it
or perhaps america would never have been
able to stop the russian invasion
but it seems like we could have finessed
this ukraine situation a little bit
better
because people are being slaughtered
nato is now mobilizing the market is
tanking
a recession is looming
and gas prices are now
above four bucks a gallon
the american people and the ukrainian
people deserve better than this
and we must not accept it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else